michel chevalet on ne sait encore
absolument rien des causes de cet
incendie
les ce que l'on peut se demander
maintenant si pourquoi c'est à 117 il
propagée si rapidement
bien sûr il ya ce facteur là il ya aussi
la sempiternelle question que se posent
bon nombre de mères de famille ce soir
c'est de savoir aussi pourquoi les
superstructures se sont effondrés si
rapidement s'ouvrir c'est la réponse la
plus facile à porter en effet cet
établissement a été construit avec une
ossature métallique qui est traditionnel
en quelque sorte et sous l'action de la
chaleur les poutres métalliques si vous
voulez s'allongent se dilate et elle
commence par repousser les murs ensuite
vers 400 degrés l'acier qui constituent
ces poutres et bien c'est acier perd sa
résistance mécanique les poutres toit
sous la charge et les plafonds les
plancher s'écroulent
alors reste le problème comme vous
l'évoquez de la rapidité de l'incendié
alors là les choses bien sûr sont
beaucoup plus complexes et de but en
blanc les tenter de faire le procès du
faire fabriquer c'est trop facile si
j'ose dire il faut d'abord voir que
l'établissement est construit la façon
suivante il a d'abord une chape de béton
une dalle de béton dessus une ossature
une charpente métallique
les murs extérieurs sont faits de dalles
de béton d'un mètre sur 0 mètre soixante
vont tous fait un combustible
enfin à l'intérieur et bien
l'aménagement traditionnel
l'établissement scolaire c'est-à-dire
des cloisons des planches est fait de
matériaux composites c'est à dire d'un
sandwich de deux plaques d'aggloméré de
plaques de bois avec un intérieur de la
mousse de polystyrène alors là me direz
vous bien ce c'est inflammable ces
combustibles
alors là c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
car dans le domaine de la tenue au feu
des matériaux il faut distinguer trois
choses trois critères qu'on mélange
souvent il ya tout d'abord ce qu'on
appelle la combustible it et du matériau
c'est à dire sa faculté son aptitude à
brûler le bois et combustibles bien sûr
le faire pour vous ne l'est pas en fait
ne l'est pas des conditions ordinaires
et pia l'inflammabilité c'est ce que
vous voyez en ce moment sur écran envoyé
un voile de coton s'enflamme avec une
simple forme de brique est par contre se
voile en tergal refuse de s'enflammer il
est ininflammable et pourtant c'est un
matériau synthétique
autre critère c'est un test qui est
effectuée au laboratoire national
d'essais à paris c'est la tenue au feu
on soumet l'échantillon de matériaux à
un four à 5 150 degrés et on regarde
comment s'enflamme le matériau et on
regarde où six cas extrêmement important
la vitesse de propagation de la flamme
conclusions deux conclusions après ces
tests tout d'abord les matériaux
nouveaux que l'on met que l'on semble
incriminés dans ce dans cet incendie est
bien les matériaux nouveaux ne sont pas
plus inflammable que les matériaux
traditionnels mais simplement la vitesse
de propagation est beaucoup plus
importante que dans les matériaux
traditionnels en raison d' en légèreté
deuxièmement quelle est la validité de
ces tests c'est là toute la question
les tests de validité de résistance au
feu ne sont obtenus qu'à partir d'un
échantillon comme vous l'avez vue qui
est extrêmement réduit qui fait environ
un demi mètre carré alors d'un demi
mètre carré à une cloison entière qui
fait plusieurs mètres carrés il y a
comme disent les spécialistes il ya un
fossé à franchir alors une boutade
peut-être mais je crois qu elle le pose
bien le problème si vous voulez pour
édicter des normes de sécurité eh bien
il faudrait dire qu'il faudrait
construire un établissement est
malheureusement y mettre de ce pour voir
comment il se comporte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]